was für ein tag für alle die unterwegs
sind in deutschland mit auto bahn
flugzeug spritpreise sind wieder
explodiert sofort mit auslaufen des
tankwarts 9 euro ticket ab heute gibt's
das nicht mehr und jetzt auch noch das
fliegen fällt morgen für ganz viele
deutsche aus morgen ist wieder
pilotenstreik bei der lufthansa und die
lufthansa sagt deshalb fast alle flüge
ab es sind nämlich morgen an den
drehkreuzen münchen in frankfurt
insgesamt rund 800 flüge und die werden
ausfallen das heißt 130 tausend
passagiere sind davon betroffen und dass
das hat die lufthansa dazu gerade gesagt
ja die vereinigung cockpit hat uns heute
nacht darüber informiert dass sie morgen
streiken wird bzw ab heute nacht
streiken wird für 24 stunden das
bedauern wir sehr insbesondere für
unsere fluggäste die darunter zu leiden
haben die passagiere sollten sich so
früh wie möglich informieren wir werden
heute im laufe des tages die
streichungen der flüge die unvermeidlich
sind in die systeme spielen und dann
wird das auch über unsere website
abrufbar sein kunden sollten tatsächlich
den status ihres fluges prüfen die
mehrheit die große mehrzahl der flüge
die für morgen geplant war muss leider
wohl ausfallen wir haben einen aus
unserer sicht sehr gutes angebot gemacht
nämlich 900 euro pro monat mehr für
jeden piloten
das entspricht einer steigerung am
unteren ende von 18 prozent am oberen
ende in der gewaltigen endstufe immer
noch fünf prozent und leider wird dieses
angebot als nicht hinreichend
betrachtet und deswegen kommt es jetzt
in diesem streik aus unserer sicht wäre
vermeidbar gewesen weil wir eben ein
gutes angebot vorgelegt haben schauen
wir an deutschlands größtem flughafen
bild reporterin dieser göttin flughafen
an frankfurt in hessen auch noch enden
die großen ferien koffer chaos gibt es
schon lisa und jetzt ist ja noch ein
viel größeres chaos quasi
vorprogrammiert
genau also heute haben wir jetzt noch
die ruhe vor dem sturm bzw die ruhe vor
dem stau derzeit sind noch keine flüge
gestrichen die lufthansa hatte aber
gesagt dass auch schon heute einzelne
flüge ausfallen können und bis samstag
natürlich auch der streit vom freitag
auswirkungen haben kann das ist
natürlich besonders bitter für die
familien die jetzt aus anderen
bundesländern wo die ferien auch noch
länger gehen zurück kommen oder auch
noch fliegen wollten beziehungsweise
leute die überhaupt frankfurt
weiterfliegen wollten die werden dann
voraussichtlich morgen hier festsitzen
wenn sie nicht umgebucht werden ja das
sind ja tolle aussichten aber was ist
jetzt wenn ich morgen meinen lufthansa
rückflug habe oder hinflug habe dann ist
er weg und ersatz gibt es wahrscheinlich
erst mal nicht mehr
also im schlimmsten fall muss man sich
gedulden bis samstag es sei denn man hat
das große glück und deshalb sollte man
sich auch direkt an seine airline wenden
dass man vielleicht noch umgebucht auf
eine andere airline umgebucht werden
kann oder auf einen anderen flug der
doch noch geht die lufthansa gesagt dass
die piloten die morgen im ausland sind
und noch zurück fliegen die dann selbst
natürlich auch zurück wollen dass die
ihren flug durchaus antreten das heißt
da könnten noch einige leute das glück
haben dass sie mit einem piloten können
sozusagen hierher zurückkommen was
allerdings auch sehr bitter es ist die
cargo wird auch bestreikt das heißt es
werden transporte am boden bleiben was
ein sehr großes risiko ist zum beispiel
für tiertransporte hier über den
frankfurter flughafen werden jährlich
millionen kleintiere transportiert küken
fische und da gab es zum beispiel 2017
so einen fall da sind tausende türken
verändert weil ein flugzeug um gedreht
wurde und diese tiere die können nur
beim bestimmten zeitraum versorgt werden
das heißt wenn so ein körper flieger
dann außerplanmäßig 24 stunden am boden
bleiben muss dann ist das natürlich
fatal weil die tiere werden dann
qualvoll verenden auch das noch lang an
unsere bild reporterin am frankfurter
flughafen dieser goethe
[Musik]